a few people realize that before i made
even the first video for khan academy
the whole point of khan academy was to
be a exercise practice feedback
reporting engine for students for
parents and for teachers and the first
videos were really just a way to
complement that so even if we go back as
as far back as 2005 we had a lot of
exercises on khan academy when we got
our first real funding in 2010 that's
where we we invested most heavily
now that the common core has come out
and not only has it come out not only
have the standards been published but
now that the there's a sense of the
adoption there's a sense of how it is
going to be assessed
we've decided to do a serious push to
intentionally make sure that our
exercises match the common core now i
want to be very clear here our intention
isn't to just map to the common core
because a lot of states have happened to
adopt it our intention is not to map to
the to just superficially take some
content and and and do a a superficial
mapping to the common core
are the whole purpose of why we're doing
this is when we looked at the standards
when we looked at the items coming out
of the assessment consortia from smarter
balanced from park we realized that this
is a very very very good standard it's a
rigorous standard it's going to measure
real deep student understanding and
there's going to be a huge need for
students and teachers and parents to
have resources where they can
get practice get feedback get
explanations around common core subjects
and so what you see right over here is a
screen of our common core site this is a
place this is really a a dashboard where
teachers or parents or even students can
look at common core standards and then
think about which khan academy content
maps to that standard it's available at
khanacademy.org
common core and you could go by
different grade levels grade 7 grade 8
and you could see the different khan
academy exercises that cover that cover
that that standard and we're actually in
process on doing this right now
we have a team of teachers of professors
of graduate students who are working
closely with us working very closely
with many of the authors of the common
core itself to make sure that we we we
intentionally create content that really
hits at the conceptual spirit of the
common core and just as a sense of the
type of team we're looking at let me of
the type of folks who are working on
this with us let me show you our team
page
so if you go to the bottom of any khan
academy page and you go to our content
specialist you'll go to this page right
over here and this is just a this is a
sample of the folks who are working with
us many of them are experts in
developmental mathematics in early
learning some of them are graduate
students some of them are professors of
mathematics at the university level but
it's a really high quality of tea a high
quality team of folks who have been
helping us make sure that we have really
deep and really peer vetted content for
intentionally created for the common
core and once again it's not just so
because 40 something states have adopted
it we want we like the common core
because we think when properly
implemented and that's a very important
thing to say when properly implemented
it is really trying to measure deep
conceptual understanding and so i
encourage you to look at the bios of all
of these folks here and we're constantly
adding more and more people to
collaborate on this effort to see the
type of content that they're creating
it's anything from fairly simple
exercises like this rewrite the
expression 75 plus 20 in the following
form and the whole point of this is to
measure we'll just in order to test
whether to someone to really understand
the distributive property and we've
built tools and widgets so that we can
do free expression entry around it so
for example 75 plus 20 we would want to
factor out let's see we could factor out
a 5 and that's 5 times
5 times we could write that as 25
or 15 i should say 15
plus 4.
and i should write this down as a
multiplication symbol just like this and
there you have it we've written this in
the form that they wanted and we can
check our answer so this is just a very
simple widget to understand does someone
understand factoring and kind of undoing
the distributive property but then
there's more complicated problems and
this is really the spirit of the common
core a lot of people a lot of times in
an algebra class you'll have people
talking about functions evaluating
functions but the spirit of the common
core is to really understand what a
function is saying and really
constructing functions so this is an
example of a word problem
an application problem where the student
has to interpret the function to make
some fairly fairly nuanced conclusions
about what's going to happen given the
data that's going on
we also have things like this that are
that are widgets that actually kind of
are are for like the word virtual
manipulatives to help build these these
these content items so for example here
move each expression to the right
category to indicate if each one is less
than equal to or greater than 6 7. so
the student will say okay let's see 5 7
plus 4 7 that's 9 7.
that's greater than
6 7's let's see 2 plus let's see this is
going to be 5 7 that's less than this
right over here is going to be let's see
this is going to be exactly equal to 6 7
and you get the general idea over here
and then we have things like this and
these are all written by experts in
their field these are written by people
who are looking very closely at the
standards looking they're working with
specialists they're working with some of
the folks who've even written the
standards and being trained by the folks
who've been written the standards to
come up with these questions to once
again really go at the conceptual
understanding that the standard is
trying to uh call out so over here in
the number 47 339 how many times less is
the value of the second three
then the value of the first three so the
second three represents 30 it's in the
tens place it's three tens this three is
in the hundreds place it represents
three hundreds so thirty is ten times
less than three hundred so you would you
type in ten so this is just an example
where actually just just coming this
fall we have a hundred we have on the
order of a hundred exercises that have
been intentionally created for the
common core and it's not just the
exercises but on top of that we have a
whole series of videos that have been
intentionally created for the common
core as well so for example this one is
interpreting features of functions we
have a whole series of videos that
explain the the underlying idea behind
what's going on so as we go over the
next few months and and definitely over
the next year especially because fall of
2014 is when you're going to have major
adoption of the common core in most of
the country
the goal is to have all of the major
standards covered from k through high
school and then even beyond for us to
really be a super set of the common core
and that's the goal by next fall even
this fall we want to cover most of the
major standards starting this fall going
through middle school and we're going to
be aggressively adding content above and
beyond that and for regions whether it's
states or or countries that are not
using the common core i want to
emphasize that we're not doing this just
to cater to the common core states we
want to do this because we want to have
a rigor we want to have rigorous math
content and exercises on the site that
would hopefully allow students to
succeed in any environment that they
that they're in so we are really
intending to be a super set not a not a
exact covering of the common core